grady judd is the sheriff of polk county
florida he joins us tonight sheriff
thanks so much for coming on you enforce
the law for a living
when violent mobs of civilians demand
punishment for people outside of our
legal system what happens to the country
well it breaks down the entire system
you know we are
a democracy because of our rule of law
and the republic fails to exist if we
don't respect that republic
and that law and it's the beginning of
the breakdown of the entire system
tucker so i mean if your job
and i assume if you know you work for
the government at any level local state
federal your job by definition is to
preserve the system that we all i
thought believed in
how do you resp if a mob shows up at a
witness's house
and smears pig blood on it do you ignore
that
not in the state of florida we don't we
lock them up we put them in jail
there's specific laws against that
trespassing
intimidating the witness interfering in
the trial
it is offensive to me as
an american to think that anyone could
do that
and get away with it i guarantee you
that won't happen in the state of
florida
and it won't happen in this county
they'll go to jail before quick
i believe you and that's one of the
reasons so many people are moving to
florida right now
but i have to ask i mean we've seen
situations like this fairly frequently
in american history we saw in the 1950s
and 60s where
municipalities decided they were going
to ignore the law and so the feds got
involved and said i'm sorry it's america
you can't violate people's civil rights
we're not going to allow it if we have
to send the 101st airborne we're going
to do that
that's not even under consideration here
the justice department
of the bite administration is doing
absolutely nothing what do you make of
that
well certainly i hope that the attorney
general
garland recognizes and upholds his
oath to the constitution we all take an
oath to support the constitution and
individual rights of
everyone people have the right to
protest
they have a right to be angry with the
government
they don't have a right to be violent
they don't have a right to attack
government officials they don't have a
right to interfere
in trials when people are trying to get
a fair trial
in the united states of america we
protect that right in the state of
florida
governor desantis is very strong
we're very strong we do what's right in
florida
all the time that's guarantee
i don't think i've heard it more clearly
put than that chef grady judd
of polk county florida appreciate your
coming on tonight
glad to be with you tucker